R
VIEWERS IN THE UNITED STATES AND
ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
IT IS MONDAY, SEPTEMBER 27th.
THIS WEEKEND, DONALD TRUMP SAID
OUT LOUD THAT HE CALLED GEORGIA
GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP AND TRIED TO
GET HIM TO THROW OUT THE 2020
ELECTION RESULTS.
LISTEN.
>> LET ME HANDLE IT.
I'LL CALL HIM UP.
I SAID, BRIAN, LISTEN, YOU HAVE
A BIG ELECTION INTEGRITY PROBLEM
IN GEORGIA.
I HOPE YOU CAN HELP US OUT AND
CALL A SPECIAL ELECTION AND
LET'S GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT
FOR THE GOOD OF THE COUNTRY.
FOR THE GOOD OF YOUR STATE.
LET'S GO.
ELECTION INTEGRITY.
WHAT COULD BE BETTER THAN THAT?
SIR, I'M SORRY, I CANNOT DO
THAT.
I SAID, WELL, I SAID YOU
CANNOT -- AND THAT'S -- LET ME
TELL YOU, THIS GUY IS A
DISASTER.
HE'S A DISASTER.
>>> IN SOME WAYS IT'S STARTLING
TO HEAR A FORMER PRESIDENT
STATE, ADMIT, CONFESS OUT LOUD
THAT HE TRIED TO OVERTURN THE
2020 ELECTION.
BUT THIS IS NOT SOME ANOMALY.
IT IS FOUNDATIONAL TO TRUMP AND
TRUMPISM NOW.
AND HE'S BEEN TELLING US THIS
OUT LOUD FOR YEARS.
HE LAID THE GROUNDWORK BEFORE
ANY VOTES WERE CAST.
>> CAN YOU GIVE A DIRECT ANSWER
YOU WILL ACCEPT THE ELECTION?
>> I HAVE TO SAY.
LOOK, I HAVE TO SEE.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY YES.
AND I DIDN'T LAST TIME EITHER
>> INDEED.
THIS WAS 2016.
>> THE LOSER CONCEDES TO THE
WINNER AND THE COUNTRY COMES
TOGETHER IN PART FOR THE GOOD OF
THE COUNTRY.
ARE YOU SAYING YOU'RE NOT
PREPARED NOW --
>> WHAT I'M SAYING IS I WILL
TELL YOU AT THE TIME.
I WILL KEEP YOU IN SUSPENSE.
>> SO THIS TIME HE ATTEMPTED TO
SOW DOUBT ABOUT MAIL-IN VOTING
DURING A PANDEMIC, MAIL-IN
VOTING, A METHOD OF VOTING
CHAMPIONED BY REPUBLICAN IN
PLACES LIKE FLORIDA FOR YEARS.
>> I THINK MAIL-IN VOTING IS
GOING TO RIG THE ELECTION.
I REALLY DO.
>> AND BEFORE THE ELECTION HE
BASICALLY HINTED HE MIGHT
DECLARE VICTORY NO MATTER WHAT.
.
>> AND WILL YOU PLEDGE TONIGHT
THAT YOU WILL NOT DECLARE
VICTORY UNTIL THE ELECTION HAS
BEEN INDEPENDENTLY CERTIFIED?
PRESIDENT TRUMP, YOU GO FIRST.
>> I'M URGING MY SUPPORTERS TO
GO INTO THE POLLS AND WATCH VERY
CAREFULLY WATCH FOR WHAT.
>> I'M 100% ON BOARD.
IF I SEE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
BALLOTS BEING MANIPULATED, I
CAN'T GO ALONG WITH THAT.
>> TENS OF THOUSANDS OF BALLOTS
WERE NOT MANIPULATED.
THAT IS A FANTASY.
SO WAS HIS DECLARATION OF
VICTORY ON ELECTION NIGHT AT
3:00 A.M.
>> THIS IS A FRAUD ON THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
THIS IS AN EMBARRASSMENT TO OUR
COUNTRY.
WE WERE GETTING READY TO WIN
THIS ELECTION.
FRANKLY, WE DID WIN THIS
ELECTION.
>> FRANKLY, HE LOST THIS
AND AFTER LOSING, HIS LAWYERS,
WHOM BILL BARR CALLED A CLOWN
SHOW, FILED LAWSUIT AFTER
LAWSUIT IN FEDERAL, STATE, AND
LOCAL COURTS, NEARLY ALL OF THEM
WERE FLAT-OUT REJECTED.
THE SUPREME COURT ON WHICH THREE
OF HIS PICKS SIT, THEY REFUSED
TO HEAR TWO CASES INVOLVING BIG
LIE CLAIM.
TRUMP TRIED TO ENLIST REPUBLICAN
STATE LEGISLAORS TO OVERTURN
STATE VOTES.
THEN HE PRESSED OFFICIALS IN
GEORGIA FOR ACTIONS FOR WHICH HE
IS CURRENTLY UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
>> ALL I WANT TO DO IS THIS.
I JUST WANT TO FIND, UH, 11,780
VOTES, WHICH IS ONE MORE THAN WE
HAVE, BECAUSE WE WON THE STATE.
>> HE TRIED TO GET THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO CALL THE ELECTION
CORRUPT.
THE ACTING ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFFREY CLARK HELPED,
DRAFTING AND PREPARING LETTERS
TO MULTIPLE STATES TO
INVESTIGATE BASELESS FRAUD
CLAIMS.
HE TRIED TO GET HIS VICE
PRESIDENT TO REJECT THE ELECTION
RESULTS BY HAVING MIKE PENCE
BLOCK THE CEREMONIAL
CONFIRMATION OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE VOTE.
A REPUBLICAN LAWYER DRAFTED A
SIX-POINT MEMO TO THROW OUT THE
RESULTS ON JANUARY 6th.
THIS WAS ON PAPER.
PENCE REFUSED TO GO ALONG AFTER
ADVICE FROM DAN QUAYLE.
FINALLY, TRUMP ENLISTED THE HELP
OF SUPPORTERS TO SHOW UP AT THE
CAPITOL JANUARY 6th, AND THEY
DID.
>> WE'RE GOING TO WALK DOWN TO
THE CAPITOL BECAUSE YOU'LL NEVER
TAKE BACK OUR COUNTRY WITH
WEAKNESS.
YOU HAVE TO SHOW STRENGTH.
AND YOU HAVE TO BE STRONG.
>> SO THE IMPORTANT THING, THIS
IS NOT OVER.
HE TALKS ABOUT IT AT EVERY
RALLY.
HE LIES ABOUT IT IN ALMOST EVERY
INTERVIEW.
HIS LIES ABOUT THE ELECTION ARE
NOT SOME INS DENTAL SIDESHOW.
HE IS THE REPUBLICAN
FRONT-RUNNER FOR PRESIDENT IN
2024.
AS WE SIT HERE, 78% OF
REPUBLICANS MORE OR LESS SAY
THEY BELIEVE HIM.
.
>> ARE IT IS A STAGGERING
NUMBER.
A NEW OPINION ESSAY IN THE
"WASHINGTON POST" HAS THIS TO
SAY ABOUT THE IMPACT OF DONALD
TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO UNDERMINE THE
PUBLIC'S FAITH IN AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
THE UNITED STATES IS HEADING
INTO ITS BIGGEST CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS SINCE THE CIVIL WAR WITH
A REASONABLE CHANCE THE NEXT
THREE TO FOUR YEARS OF INCIDENCE
OF MASS VIOLENCE, BREAKDOWN OF
FEDERAL AUTHORITY, AND THE
DIVISION OF THE COUNTRY INTO
WARRING RED AND BLUE ENCLAVES.
TO DISCUSS THIS, CASEY HUNT, CNN
ANCHOR ANALYST AND HOST OF THE
CNN POLITICAL BRIEFING PODCAST,
DAVID CHALIAN.
ONE OF THE SCARY THINGS ABOUT
THIS OPINION ESSAY IS WARNING
SIGNS MAY BE OBSCURED BY OTHER
EVENTS, RIGHT?
THIS COULD HAPPEN.
SCARY THINGS COULD HAPPEN.
WE MAY NOT EVEN NOTICE THEM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
SEPTEMBER?
.
>> FIRST OF ALL, BEYOND HOW
DEPRESSING THIS ALL IS, WHICH IT
IS, IT'S DANGEROUS.
THIS IS HAPPENING BEFORE OUR
EYES.
JOHN JUST WENT THROUGH THAT
EXTENSIVE HISTORY LESSON OF
EVERYTHING THAT DONALD TRUMP HAD
DONE THAT LED US TO THIS MOMENT.
BUT THE IMPORTANT POINT IS THE
ONE THAT YOU MENTIONED AT THE
END THERE, WHICH IS THIS IS
STILL ONGOING.
THIS IS HAPPENING NOW.
AND IT'S NOT JUST CONVINCING THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ABOUT THE LIE,
WHICH HE HAS DONE SUCCESSFULLY.
BUT IT IS ALSO CHANGING THE LAWS
IN STATES SO THAT HE CAN OR
ALLIES OF HIS CAN IN 2022, AND
IF HE DOES RUN AND IS NOMINEE IN
2024, CAN MANIPULATE -- ANOTHER
POLL NUMBER IN OUR POLL BESIDES
78% IS A SLIM MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS ACTUALLY BELIEVE,
BELIEVE THAT ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
WILL OVERTURN RESULTS FOR
PARTISAN PURPOSES.
YOU DON'T HAVE A FUNCTIONING
DEMOCRACY IF YOU DON'T HAVE
BUY-IN TO THE RESULTS OF A FREE
AND FAIR ELECTION.
THAT'S IT.
THAT'S THE CORE THING.
AND THAT IS THE DOUBT THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS NOW SOWN INTO
OUR DEMOCRATIC BEING.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE LINE
THAT HELD ON JANUARY 6th AND
INTO THE CERTIFICATION OF THE
ELECTION.
IT WAS A HANDFUL OF STATE
ELECTION OFFICIALS.
IT WAS MIKE PENCE ON THE PHONE
WITH DAN QUAYLE.
IT WAS MARK MILLEY AND OTHERS AT
THE PENTAGON.
THE TRUMP TEAM IS SYSTEMATICALLY
TRYING TO UNDERMINE THAT.
AFTER PEOPLE LIKE BRAD
RAFFENSPERGER STOOD UP.
THEY ARE WORKING TO CHANGE THE
SYSTEMS.
I WILL SAY, AND BRIANNA, I KNOW
YOU TALKED TO SO MANY ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
WHEN TRUMP WAS FIRST ELECTED,
EVERYONE THOUGHT THEY WERE IN ON
THE JOKE.
THEY WERE GOING TO HANG AROUND,
DO THEIR BEST TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST HIM.
REALLY HE WAS JUST EVENTUALLY
GOING TO LOSE.
HE WAS GOING TO GO AWAY.
AND BIT BY BIT THAT BECAME THE
STRATEGY THEY USED EVERY SINGLE
TIME.
AND I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
BELIEVED THEM.
THEY WERE WILLING TO SAY, OKAY,
THAT SEEMS RIGHT.
MAYBE THIS SUSPECT AS BAD AS
PEOPLE WERE MAKING IT OUT TO BE.
THERE WAS A NAME FOR IT, TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
THEN CAME JANUARY 6th, WHICH IS
SOMETHING I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD SIGH IN MY LIFETIME.
IT CERTAINLY CHANGED THE GAME
FOR ME BEING THERE.
I REMEMBER THINKING AS WE WERE
WATCHING THESE PEOPLE, SURELY I
SHOULD NOT RESPONSIBLY REPORT ON
TELEVISION THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
INVADING THE CAPITOL.
BUT THAT IS ACTUALLY WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
AND NOW THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
TRYING TO WHITEWASH IT.
I THINK THAT TELLS YOU EXACTLY
WHERE WE'RE GOING.
>> THE LIE HAS BECOME THEIR
TRUTH.
THEY ARE NOT JUST KNOWLEDGE
WHATTING HIM.
THEY HAVE SORT OF BECOME THEM.
AND THE OTHER THING I FIND
INTERESTING IN A TERRIBLE WAY IS
THAT DONALD TRUMP CONTINUES,
DAVID, TO, YOU KNOW, IN HE'S
RALLIES OR IN INTERVIEWS TO JUST
ADMIT THE WRONGDOING PUBLICLY.
I MEAN, HE CLEARLY DOES NOT FEEL
THERE ARE ANY CONSEQUENCES.
HE IS JUST RIGHT OUT THERE WITH
IT.
>> CLEARLY.
HE IS A LOT OF THINGSMENT
SECRETIVE IS NOT ONE OF THEM.
HE DOES SHOW US AND TELL US, AS
HE DID THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRETY
OF HIS PRESIDENCY, WHO HE IS,
WHAT HE'S THINKING AT ANY GIVEN
MOMENT.
YOU'RE RIGHT, THERE IS NO FEAR
OF REPERCUSSION BECAUSE THERE
ARE NO REPERCUSSIONS.
THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE COME TO
LEARN.
TO THE POINT THAT YOU'RE MAKING
ABOUT ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
REPUBLICANS WHO APPROACH TRUMP
WITH THAT STRATEGY, THEY'RE JUST
AS COMPLICIT IN THIS MOMENT OF
OUR DEMOCRACY BEING IN PERIL AS
IS DONALD TRUMP FOR PERPETRATING
THE BIG LIE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THEY'VE
CHOSEN TO ALLOW TO SEEP INTO OUR
BODY POLITIC THAT IS CHIPPING
AWAY AT OUR CORE DEMOCRACY HERE
BECAUSE THEY REFUSE TO PUT HIM
AWAY.
AND BECAUSE, AGAIN, AS YOU SAID,
HE'S SUCCESSFUL AT GETTING THE
PARTY FAITHFUL TO BELIEVE IN
THIS LIE.
BUT THIS SILENCE IS TRULY PART
OF THE PROBLEM HERE.
>> AND THE REALITY IS THIS HAS
BEEN DONALD TRUMP'S M.O. THROUGH
HIS ENTIRE LIFE.
HE IS A CREATION OF THE
ATTENTION THAT SURROUNDS HIM,
RIGHT?
TO A GREATER EXTENT THAT, YES,
HIS FATHER BUILT BUILDINGS IN
NEW YORK.
HE TALKS ABOUT HOW HE MOVED INTO
MANHATTAN AND ALL OF THIS.
SO MUCH WAS AN EDIFICE OF
PUBLICITY THAN IT WAS ACTUAL
WORK.
AND I THINK THAT APPLIES IN
POLITICS AS WELL.
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE.
HE, WITH HIS SUPPORTERS, HAVE
DISCREDITED ALL OTHER
INFORMATION TO THE POINT THAT
PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE SOURCES OR
PLACES WHERE WE ARE BOUND BY
REALITY AND RULES AND ACTUALLY
SAYING THINGS THAT WE CAN PROVE
OR POINT TO AND SAY, HEY, IT'S
TRUE.
BUT NOBODY BELIEVES IT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE ALL BEEN CONDITIONED
BY HIM NOT TO.
AND, YES, THE LEADERS ARE